xbox series x unboxings have begun
new miles morales footage has hit
instagram and a dreamcast mini
could possibly be on the way i'm persia
and this is your save state for monday
october 12th
we're still about a month away from the
official launch of the xbox series x
but unboxing videos are already popping
up online
youtube user willy crow posted the video
of the unboxing that showed off what
you'll experience next
month the packaging has its black and
green xbox branding as expected and when
opening the box the console is presented
nicely
easy to access and is wrapped in black
paper to prevent dust and scratches
we also get a glimpse of the controller
and other accessories in the box which
all look pretty cool
there is also an image on reddit that
shows a pile of xbox series xboxes ready
to go which means we might be seeing
even more early unboxing soon so what do
you think of the packaging did you know
we also got our hands on the series x
we've talked about that and all things
next gen on our weekly show
generation next so be sure to check that
out on our channel
we got our first look at miles trademark
hoodie costume
the same outfit he wore in into the
spider verse and a daily bugle article
that talks about how
the city watched as spidey's new partner
trained along the rooftops this tells us
that miles has already spent some time
with his new abilities before the game
starts and that peter parker
will likely play a significant role in
the game as miles's mentor
spider-man miles morales is out on
november 12th on ps4 and ps5
one more month sega just released the
game gear micro in japan
and it's thinking about which console to
shrink next
sega creative producer yosuke ogunari
said in a famitsu interview for the next
mini we are considering
everything that has been imagined by
everyone if i have to say some names it
could be an
sg-1000 mini or a dreamcast mini the
original dreamcast was home to crazy
taxi
jet set radio fantasy star online and
more
whichever console is chosen won't be
here for a few years but at least we
know there's still a chance so stay
tuned to gamespot for any future updates
that's all for today's news but you
should also check out our other new
videos we posted on our channel today
hope you have a great start to your week
and we'll see you at your next save
state tomorrow
bye
[Music]
you